tis the season for holiday parties and
get-togethers the new Epicurious app can
help you find dozens of drink options
that will be the talk of your next
Gathering Epicurious digital director
Maggie Hoffman is here with three of her
favorites good morning good to see you
all right so what are some of the big
trends that we're seeing this year you
know everyone's into bitter drinks the
spagliato is so hot right now so what we
have here for you are some real
cocktails but they're made without
alcohol okay you can serve them in your
party it lets people Pace themselves
lets people drink or not drink up to
them bitter drinks mean sour is that
what that means
the bitter is like like a Negroni uh
things that are that Italian aperitif
style a lot of these are great for going
with food or before you eat get you
hungry you can get all your holiday
snacks in the new Epicurious app and all
of these drinks plus lots of cocktails
so you can have a mix it doesn't drink
that's exactly right when you said
bitter recipe at parity what does that
mean I I really don't so I like a sweet
drink or any of these sweet drinks they
won't be just sweet they'll be balanced
but there is some fruit you know we have
some pomegranate fruits in this one and
some cherry juice in this one
um and this one is sort of a fizzy soda
that has a little bit of tart lemon lime
but also fennel so you want to walk us
through it walk us through let me try it
as you talk about it try it as we talk
okay this one what do we have here
so this is a soda that's not too sweet a
little bit tart you make a quick syrup
with herbs and fennel and then it has
lemon juice lime juice club soda super
easy I've made I've made a drink for
Gail before it uh I should put a little
more sugar yeah I do I like it you make
a little syrup ahead of time so you can
always add more to your taste
all right next up we have looks like a
goblet of wine here but what is it
really so I think it's nice it looks
like an adult drink yeah yeah and a
proper glass I like and it's warm this
is warm yeah so this is like a mulled
wine but without alcohol
oh okay and it gets its flavor from a
smoky tea lapsing tsuchong tea yeah and
then tart cherry juice I like that yeah
keep that warm in your slow cooker
through the whole party and you always
have an option for everyone and no one's
going to be asking you oh you're not
drinking tonight you can just you know
exactly it looks it fits right in it's
none of their business you can say I
have an adult beverage yeah right you
can play it off and what about this one
I'm the one at the party saying can you
make Shirley temples I just asked
someone last night and I said you could
make it sweet with the Grenadine you can
give me extra grenade I'm that guy and
now you have lots of this is a new
education for me this is fabulous yeah
what is this one Maggie so this is
called life of the party it's from
bartender Natasha David
and this is sort of The Cutting Edge
I like it this one I do like cinnamon
syrup and it has pomegranate juice and a
little bit of non-alcoholic sparkling
wine plus a non-alcoholic aperitif
called Gia okay there's one I can drink
right here very good yeah one this is
terrific now if uh if you have a certain
kind of Uncle that has a flask in his
pocket and he wants to mix in maybe
maybe not with this one but with these
two go for it yeah anything you'd
recommend yeah so I would probably
gin maybe on both of these because those
herbal flavors will go it will match
perfectly with the herbal flavors in
here this is a trend you're seeing
though more people are coming to parties
saying I don't really want to be curious
in my neighborhood we now have a
non-alcoholic drink shop absolutely and
there's so many new products that make
it quicker to make non-alcoholic drinks
like this one it tastes really
complicated but it's super easy to make
but why do you think that's happening
Maggie yeah so yeah people need a night
off sometimes people are trying to work
out in the morning a little more balance
um some people anchor morning shows
really or sometimes you just get tired
of the peer pressure and you want to
play it off and act like you're drinking
but you're really not and maybe it's a
long party yeah you're right about that
yeah Maggie Hoffman thank you so much
now if you want to make these drinks at
home visit our CBS mornings Facebook and
Twitter pages for the recipes